هي صدفه ام لغز ان يحمل يوم الجمعه موعدا
لاعلان البنوك الكبيره في التاريخ الحديث
عن انهيارها وفق تغريده ذا كوبيس لتر وهو
حساب على تويتر يتابع احداث السوق لاحظ ان
الكشف عن ازمات المصارف الكبيره او
انهيارها لطالما جاء في ايام الجمعه ففي
يوم الجمعه الرابع عشر من مارس من عام
2008 تعرض مصرف بير سيرنز لازمه سيوله
فيما شهد يوم الجمعه الثاني عشر من سبتمبر
من ذات العام اخر يوم تداول قبل اعلان
مصرف لممبرز فلاسا الامر تكرر مع الاعلان
عن انهيار مصرف واشنطن في السادس والعشرين
من نفس العام
وفي الربع الاول من العام الحالي تجدد
الانهيار في ايام الجمعه من مارس الماضي
حيث تم الاعلان عن انهيار ثلاثه بنوك
اثنان منها وهما مصرف سيليكون فالي وبنكشر
الامريكيان اللذان وضعت السلطات الامريكيه
يدها عليهما والثالث كريدي سويس عندما قدم
بنك عرضا لشرائه تجنبا الانهياره تقرير
لسي ان ان فسر السبب نافيا الصدفه بل كشف
ان ادارات المصارف الماذومه او المشرفه
على الانهيار تختار عدم اثاره زعر العملاء
خلال ايام الاسبوع وتنتظر يوم الجمعه الذي
يتبعه يومان يمثلان عطله نهايه الاسبوع ما
يؤمن لمسؤولين وقتا كافيا للتخطيط لعمليه
استحواذ او للتراجع عن خطط بهدوء يخلو من
ارباك عملاء المصارف